seis cargueros ucranianos cargados con
cereal y trigo de este mismo país han
salido esta mañana de los puertos de
Ucrania en dirección a Turquía son los
primeros que salen después de que ayer
Rusia volvés a entrar al acuerdo por las
exportaciones de cereal y grano grano
del que salió este mismo sábado después
de un ataque con drones acuáticos y
aéreos en contra de la flota rusa en el
mar Negro ayer por la noche el
presidente durko representan explicó que
después de unos largos días de
negociación en que los barcos seguían
saliendo sobre todo gracias a la
mediación de Naciones Unidas y de
Turquía a Rusia Espera que estos barcos
puedan continuar funcionando y que vayan
sobre todo a países de África y de
países pobres de Asia explicado erdogan
que Rusia se busca garantizarse sobre
todo la seguridad de sus barcos y de eso
flota naval en el mar Negro durante la
ofensiva que realiza Rusia desde febrero
de este año en Ucrania sin embargo la
vuelta de Rusia a este acuerdo no
significa que este pueda dura durante
muchos meses más según explicado esta
misma mañana el kremlin a Rusia que haya
vuelto a ese acuerdo no significa que no
pueda salirse a partir del 19 de
noviembre cuando tiene que rebotarse
este acuerdo todos los miembros de este
pacto firmado en Estambul este Julio
pueden salirse del acuerdo en el
lateralmente y romperlo así ha explicado
Moscú que puede ser posible que músculo
haga en el futuro si no ves las
condiciones apropiadas según ellos
mismos decidirán para la resolución y la
continuación de este acuerdo que ha
servido para bajar mundialmente los
precios del cereal y del